[Music]
big holiday weekend you excited well
tomorrow night of course is the Jewish
holiday of Passover that's right yeah or
or as we call it here in Los Angeles
Cinco de Mato no no it got exactly what
it deserved it was perfect what else is
going on Mega Millions controversy
getting stranger by the day it's a very
strange story yesterday the Maryland
woman who claims she's the Mega Millions
winner held a press conference where she
not only failed to present the winning
ticket but also quickly asked the press
to leave yeah yeah in other words she's
full of mega now even though
this woman claims she won Mega Millions
surveillance footage shows the ticket
was purchased by a man yeah so either
she's lying or we're all trapped inside
the new Tyler Perry movie that wouldn't
mind be fine yeah doesn't I get to wear
a dress it's being reported that
President Obama admitted he's a Trekkie
you know that he says it says the
Trekkie
which explains why the president is
polling very high with virgins aged 45
to 60
who would admit to that to a pollster
what being a virgin like I'm a 48 year
old virgin they can just tell about what
t-shirt you're wearing all that when you
answer the door at your mom's house this
week Yahoo announced the firing of 2,000
employees yeah in an effort to figure
out just what prompted the layoffs Yahoo
employees spent hours googling the
answer
[Applause]
[Music]
that's my guy getting caught looking at
porn you can see it this way - that way
you're the one catching me great science
news scientists have found the remains
of a large dinosaur covered in a
combination of feathers and fur the
feathered and furred dinosaur was found
in China but reportedly had hopes of
making it to Broadway kanye west in the
news Kanye West has recorded a new song
in which he says he has fallen in love
yeah Kanye must be in love because the
song is entitled you remind me of me
[Applause]